ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo video
sono vestito da un gas come i ragazzi
qua perché stiamo registrando la seconda
parte del rito dei fan della among us
quindi ragazzi non perdete lo nel
frattempo vi lasciamo con il video di
oggi su castro qualità
[Musica]
secondo me sta partita finisce malissimo
[Applauso]
mi fate per favore facoltà ma scusate
chi è che allora perché è morto ma la
chiamo io so chi è stato ore pare ma il
re ha trovato il cadavere di martina era
tipo sotto nei corridoi quelli tipo
divisi a metano e mi è passato se non
sbaglio vessicchio da vicino questi
c'era come mamma mia ragazzi che culo
non mi ha visto
mamma mia ragazzi ma veramente non mi
hanno votato
allora come ho fatto a non vedermi che
bobo non era babbo borino anzi mi ha
salvato la vita quindi è un grande
iscrivetevi al suo fottutissimo canale
io perché l'ho ammazzato lì perché le
luci erano spente quindi nella mia testa
ho detto che lo ammazzo perché tanto non
mi vengono però nel momento preciso in
cui si sono accese dell'uci io l'ho
ammazzato quindi è stato mega rischioso
ma mega quindi incredibile raga
incredibile ha avuto un culo ma di
quelli pazzeschi ma un culo veramente
finale mammamia ragazze ska sta roba
ma a capo eravamo in tanti lì perché non
posso difendere la molara non possiamo
farci carico ma chi vuole potrà andarci
io voto c'è stato registrato un video
così ora commettere tutti mi votano
anche se non sono esatte non possiamo
anche aspettare tanto stiamo finendo le
bratz quindi per me raga dobbiamo fare
la fatica a fare la doppia dobbiamo fare
la definiamo ne manca uno dobbiamo fare
la doppia al momento è al momento di
fare la doppia ebadi
se non facciamo la doppia gobba di è
persa dobbiamo stare insieme e fare la
doppia tantissimo tantissimo dobbiamo
fare la doppia no vieni signore
grazie
era il tempo storico
[Musica]
ho visto che noi ha visti e facilmente
incredibile una paura terribile
l'oro è cosa dici cosa è successo
no hay que no no raga scusami loro poi
ti faccio parlare però stavo andando ero
nel corridoio quello che va in su quello
dei due e vabbè avete capito e tipo vedo
che noia che esce dalla botola che fanno
dare la partita che cosa però come mare
dalla vento davanti a me basta benedetti
ma sentito il riso mentre che noi
io vorrei sapere lorenzo cosa viene sta
però io ho usati in caffetteria c'era il
corpo di nomi ricordo con atc e stavano
uscendo esattamente ciò che noi ha
quindi avrei votato o uno l'altro laico
e cosa vediamo dai scudiero e l'evento
non le uso quindi spazi per l'amor di
dio stai zitta stai b
no no no no
così
che goduria quando politica la gente che
non c'entra in casa eccitanti ma a volte
ma che mai
ma no per favore respiro ragazzi se non
fa ci foste voi altro che non faremo
nessuno farebbe vi usi grazie madonna
raga bellissimo io io veramente io penso
di aver trovato la compagnia di among us
più bella che esista sul pianeta perché
come si scassa aspetta mi hanno sparato
quando a fare la tasche ho visto il
marrone morto io ero dietro corridoi
braga e cesca comunque mi ha visto ma in
realtà mi ha accusato a caso perché
disse che sei molla io mi fido di quello
che ha detto loro e prima che siete
uscite voi due quindi se una è morta
l'altra era di fianco quindi io ci prova
aveva è frate allora sei contano dai
anche anche se noi a badia questo punto
perché matera bello perché lo penso e
cesca io lorenzo cesca stava andando
insieme abbiamo visto il corpo insieme
lorenzo primo quindi o babbi serba
adesso che mi accusi cioè mi dispiace ma
sei sicura che riceve accusate di brutto
cioè non lo so io era che la smetta
votare in realtà non vorrebbe dico la
verità non volevo io vabbè allora
chiediamo però non mi accusate perché
c'è che senso ha
io ho votato bandi perché non ha senso
quello che ha detto sinceramente io lo
chiamo la mia vita di un assenso la mia
vita
la ragazza che guarda le persone
comunque cit baldi perfetto allora devo
stare a te quante abbiamo limiti alle
tasche sono tutte è la prima volta che
la crew mente devo fare tutte le tasche
in generale finis definite tutte per il
fisco tutte per prima ma è la prima
volta che in questi casi ne trova in
difficoltà però vabbè strano eh non è
mai successe un evento vessicchio e via
fai schifo ma aiuta e vessicchio
vessicchio mi segue vale detto infame e
lui non è pepi cesca e lui e vessicchio
che tenta di uccidere cosa devo fare qua
due è come il codice di verifica del
boudoir perfetto maledetto che si cresca
vieni qua cesca cesca semi sia questa
missione cerca quindi qua allora no vai
via
basta ma basta allora pensi che mi son
paura di te pensi che non c'è paura è
pensi che non c'è paura di idee la
marcia si che cio paura via
no ragazzi che anzi rivivere per
vessicchio che anzi rivivere un posto
gioca così trotta ma la vuoi smettere di
seguirmi scusatemi aperto basta allora
sarebbe un pazzo bandiera cui sarah è
tutta così perché poi vedremo tutti in
albero boh mio papà cosa stai facendo è
un sacrificio vero questo gargano
buttatevi fuori vi prego giochi fino ai
dibattiti allora va da sola un certo
punto mi sono attaccata sotto però non
mi ha visto che scappava scappato che
prodotto io ero con derby ma io sono
stato solo anche quando si che una volta
la sopra che significa allora donna che
tasche stavi facendo
attenzione oggi ci va bene tutto quello
che una tasca d'emergenza con un riccio
mai anche simpatica una delle più belle
da crew ma bellissima per i ragazzi i
profeti vi sia piaciuto noi continuano
le riprese e lo trovate quale cresce
periodi negativi 14 quindi no ma quando
hai questo video e il giovedì
no mercoledì ma io comunque previste
anche a cagli pantella se non per la tv
video bella
[Musica]
ma